>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR THOSE KIND WORDS OF
INTRODUCTION.
I MUST TELL YOU THAT I'M
DELIGHTED, VERY PLEASED AND
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HEAR YOU LOOK
GOOD!
[LAUGHTER]
THE WEATHER IS GOOD, RAIN STAYED
AWAY.
I'M HAPPY.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF YOU.
FELLOWS OF HARVARD UNIVERSITY,
MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF OVERSEERS, MEMBERS
OF THE ALUMNI BOARD,
DISTINGUISHED DEANS, GUESTS,
FACULTY AND ALL OF THE STUDENTS,
ALL OF THE WONDERFUL GRADUATES,
AND MADAM PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP,
THANK YOU FOR GETTING IN GOOD
TROUBLE!
[LAUGHTER]
NECESSARY TROUBLE.
TO LEAD THIS GREAT UNIVERSITY.
I WANT TO TAKE JUST A MOMENT TO
HONOR
THE TENURE OF A GREAT LEADER,
WHO, THROUGH HER COURAGE AND
VISION, WORKED TO LEAD THIS
HISTORIC UNIVERSITY TO EVEN
HIGHER HEIGHTS.
MADAM PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
BEING A FRIEND, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THANK YOU FOR USING
YOUR OFFICE TO MOVE HARVARD
TOWARD A MORE ALL-INCLUSIVE
INSTITUTION.
[APPLAUSE]
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY, YOU
REALIZED THAT THE BRILLIANT MIND
IS NOT CONFINED TO ONE
DISCIPLINE OR ONE WAY OF
THINKING.
IN FACT, TRUE GENIUS SEES
CONNECTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
ACROSS BARRIERS, TO BUILD A NEW
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORLD
AROUND US.
CREATING ONE HARVARD IS MUCH
LIKE THE WORK I DEDICATED MY
LIFE TO.
EVER SINCE AS A YOUNG GIRL YOU
WROTE A LETTER
TO PRESIDENT EISENHOWER AS A
LITTLE GIRL, YOU HAVE BEEN
RESPONDING TO THE CRY FOR HUMAN
DIGNITY THAT RINGS OUT IN OUR
WORLD.
YOU USED YOUR VISION AND YOUR
TALENT, YOU USED THE GREAT
RESOURCES OF THIS UNIVERSITY TO
RESPOND TO THAT CALL, AND I
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION
TO HUMAN UNITY IN OUR WORLD
TODAY.
I SAY
TO EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU WHO
GRADUATED FROM THIS UNIVERSITY,
YOU MUST LEAD.
YOU'RE NEVER TOO YOUNG TO LEAD,
YOU'RE NEVER TOO OLD TO LEAD!
WE NEED YOUR LEADERSHIP NOW MORE
THAN EVERY BEFORE.
WE NEED IT!
[APPLAUSE]
WE MUST SAVE OUR COUNTRY!
WE MUST SAVE IT!
[APPLAUSE]
WE MUST SAVE OUR DEMOCRACY.
THERE ARE FORCES IN AMERICA
TODAY AND AROUND THE WORLD
TRYING TO TAKE US TO SOME OTHER
PLACE.
OUR FOREMOTHERS AND FOREFATHERS
BROUGHT US TO THIS PLACE.
MAYBE OUR FOREMOTHERS AND OUR
FOREFATHER'S ALL CAME TO THIS
GREAT WORLD IN DIFFERENT SHIPS
BUT AS THE LATE GREAT RANDOLPH
SAID "WE ARE ALL IN THE SAME
BOAT NOW" AND WE MUST LOOK OUT
FOR EACH OTHER AND CARE FOR EACH
OTHER.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU'RE NEVER TOO YOUNG OR TOO
OLD TO LEAD!
TO SPEAK UP!
SPEAK OUT!
AND GET IN GOOD TROUBLE,
NECESSARY TROUBLE.
YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO STAND ON
THE SIDELINES.
ANOTHER GENERATION OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE NOT SO YOUNG
ARE INSPIRED TO GET IN THE WAY.
STUDENTS FROM HARVARD, DR.
COLE,
WHO I HAVE BEEN KNOWING FOR MANY
YEARS CAME TO MISSISSIPPI, CAME
TO THE SOUTH AND GAVE EVERYTHING
YOU HAD.
DURING THE 63 YOUNG MEN THAT I
KNEW, ANA GOODMAN, NICK WILL YOU
SAY SHRENER AND JAMES GAVE THEIR
LIVES WHILE THEY WERE HELPING
PEOPLE TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
THE VOTE IS PRECIOUS.
IT'S ALMOST SACRED.
IT IS THE MOST POWERFUL,
NONINSTRUMENT OR TOOL WE HAVE IN
A DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY AND WE MUST
USE T IF WE FAIL TO USE IT, WE
WILL LOSE IT.
[APPLAUSE]
SO DURING THIS ELECTION YEAR, I
URGE YOU, I PLEAD WITH YOU TO DO
WHAT YOU CAN TO SAVE AND RESCUE
AMERICA.
TO DO WHAT YOU CAN TO SAVE THE
PLANET!
SAVE THIS SPACESHIP WE CALL
EARTH AND LEAVE IT A LITTLE
CLEANER, A LITTLE GREENER, AND A
LITTLE MORE PEACEFUL.
FOR GENERATIONS YET UNBORN.
[APPLAUSE]
WE HAVE A MISSION AND A MANDATE
TO GO OUT THERE, PLAY A ROLE AND
PLAY IT SO WELL AS DR.
KING
WOULD SAY, THAT NO ONE ELSE CAN
PLAY IT ANY BETTER.
SMV YOU HAVE HEARD ME SAY FROM
TIME TO TIME THAT I GREW UP IN
RURAL ALABAMA ON A FARM.
PICKING COTTON, GATHERING
PEANUTS, GATHERING CORN,
SOMETIMES I WOULD BE OUT THERE
WORKING AND MY MOTHER WOULD SAY,
"BOY, YOU'RE FALLING BEHIND!
YOU NEED TO CATCH UP" AND I
WOULD SAY "THIS IS HARD WORK AND
SHE SAID "HARD WORK NEVER KILLED
ANYBODY AND I SAID I SAY ABOUT
TO KILL ME!
[LAUGHTER]
WE NEED TO WORK HARD!
THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE.
THESE SMART GRADUATES WILL LEAD
US.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS LEAD US,
AND GUYS, I SAY TO YOU, IF
YOU'RE NOT MINDFUL, THE WOMEN
ARE GOING TO LEAD US!
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
IT IS MY BELIEF, IT IS MY
FEELING AS A TRAVELLER OF
AMERICA THAT THE WOMEN AND YOUNG
PEOPLE, HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS,
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS WILL LEAD US AS
PART OF A NONVIOLENT REVOLUTION.
WE WILL CREATE AN AMERICA THAT
IS BETTER, A LITTLE MORE HUMANE
AND NO ONE, BUT NO ONE CAN DENY
US OF THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE OR TWO
WORDS TO THE GRADUATES.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND TAKE IT
ALL IN.
BUT TOMORROW, I HOPE YOU ROLL UP
YOUR SLEEVES, BECAUSE THE WORLD
IS WAITING FOR TALENTED MEN AND
WOMEN TO LEAD IT TO A BETTER
PLACE.
DURING THE 60s, PEOPLE LITERALLY
PUT THEIR BODIES ON THE LINE!
MANY CAME FROM THIS UNIVERSITY,
CAME FROM CAMBRIDGE, FROM
BOSTON, THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THROUGHOUT AMERICA.
JUST THINK A FEW SHORT YEARS AGO
THAT BLACK PEOPLE AND WHITE
PEOPLE COULDN'T BE SEATED
TOGETHER ON A GREYHOUND BUSINESS
OR TRAILWAY BUS, LEAVING
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO TRAVEL
THROUGH VIRGINIA, NORTH
CAROLINA, SOUTH CAROLINA,
GEORGIA, ALABAMA, MISSISSIPPI.
WE WERE ON OUR WAY TO NEW
ORLEANS TO TEST A DECISION OF
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
WE WERE BEATEN, ARRESTED, AND
MORE THAN 400 OF US WERE JAILED.
MY SEAT MATE WAS A YOUNG WHITE
GENTLEMAN FROM CONNECTICUT.
WE ARRIVED IN A SMALL TOWN IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE WERE BEATEN, LEFT BLOODY.
BUT MANY YEARS LATER AND THIS
WAS MAY, 1961, SAME YEAR THAT
BARACK OBAMA WAS BORN, BUT MANY
YEARS LATER, ONE OF THE GUYS
THAT BEAT US CAME TO MY OFFICE
IN WASHINGTON.
HE GOT INFORMATION FROM A LOCAL
REPORTER.
HE WAS IN HIS 70s, HIS SON CAME
WITH HIM IN HIS 40s.
HE SAID, MR.
LEWIS, I'M ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT BEAT YOU.
BEAT YOUR SEATMATE.
I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF THE KLAN.
HE SAID "WILL YOU FOR GIVE ME?"
"I WANT TO APOLOGIZE."
"WILL YOU ACCEPT MY APOLOGY?
WILL YOU FOR GIVE ME?"
HIS SON STARTED CRYING, HE
STARTED CRYING AND I SAID I FOR
GIVE YOU.
I ACCEPT YOUR APOLOGY.
THEY HUGGED ME, I HUGGED THEM
BACK AND I CRIED WITH THEM.
IN POWER OF THE WAY OF PEACE,
THE POWER OF LOVE, IT IS THE
POWER OF THE PHILOSOPHY AND
DISCIPLINE OF NONVIOLENCE.
WE NEED TO CREATE A SOCIETY
WHERE WE CAN BE RECONCILED AND
LAY DOWN THE BURDEN OF HATH FOR
HATE IS TOO HEAVY OF A BURDEN TO
BEAR.
[APPLAUSE]
50 YEARS AGO THE MAN THAT I
ADMIRED, THE MAN THAT WAS LIKE A
BROTHER, MARTIN LUTHER KING,
JUNIOR, WAS TAKEN FROM US.
WHEN WE HEARD THAT DR.
KING HAD
BEEN ASSASSINATED I WAS IN
INDIANAPOLIS, INDIANA
CAMPAIGNING WITH BOBBY KENNEDY.
I CRIED.
STOPPED CRYING AND I SAID TO
MYSELF "WE STILL HAVE BOBBY."
TWO MONTHS LATER BOBBY KEPT DID
I WAS GONE -- KENNEDY WAS GONE
AND I CRIED SOME MORE.
TODAY WE'VE GOT TO GET RID OF
OUR ARE TEARS AND NOT BE DOWN
AND NOT GET LOST IN THE SEA OF
DESPAIR.
WE'VE GOT TO BE HOPEFUL AND KEEP
THE FAITH AND TURN THE SHIP
AROUND.
WE CAN DO IT AND WE MUST DO IT!
[APPLAUSE]
HERE AT HARVARD YOU'VE BEEN WELL
TRAINED.
YOU MUST LEAD.
YOU MUST GET OUT THERE AND AS
DR.
KING WOULD SAY, BE A
HEADLIGHT, NOT A TAILLIGHT!
IT'S YOUR TIME, IT'S YOUR
CALLING.
DURING THE 60s I GOT ARRESTED A
FEW TIMES, 40 TIMES!
[LAUGHTER]
AND SINCE I'VE BEEN IN CONGRESS
ANOTHER FIVE TIMES!
[APPLAUSE]
AND I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GET
ARRESTED AGAIN!
MY PHILOSOPHY IS VERY SIMPLE,
WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT RIGHT, NOT FAIR, NOT JUST,
STAND UP!
SAY SOMETHING!
SPEAK UP AND SPEAK OUT!
[APPLAUSE]
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP AS A YOUNG
BOY IN RURAL ALABAMA, 50 MILES
FROM MONTGOMERY, I HAD AN AUNT
BY THE NAME OF SINEVA AND MY
AUNT LIVED IN A SHOTGUN HOUSE,
HERE AT HARVARD YOU NEVER SEEN A
SHOTGUN HOUSE, YOU DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
[LAUGHTER]
ONE WAY IN, ONE WAY OUT.
WHAT IS A SHOTGUN HOUSE?
OLD HOUSE, DIRT YARD.
SOMETIMES MY AUNT SINEVA WOULD
GO OUT ON THE WEEKEND, FRIDAY OR
SATURDAY, AND TAKE A BRUSH BROOM
MADE FROM DOGWOOD BRANCHES AND
SWEEP THE YARD VERY CLEAN.
ONE SATURDAY AFTERNOON FEW OF MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS, COUSINS,
ABOUT 15 OF US YOUNG CHILDREN
WERE PLAYING IN HER DIRT YARD.
AND AN UNBELIEVABLE STORM CAME
UP.
THE WIND STARTED BLOWING, THE
THUNDER STARTED ROLLING AND THE
LIGHTNING STARTED FLASHING AND
SHE TOLD US TO COME IN.
WE WENT IN.
THE WIND CONTINUED TO BLOW, THE
THUNDER CONTINUED TO ROLL, THE
LIGHTNING CONTINUED TO FLASH,
AND THE RAIN CONTINUED TO BEAT
ON THIS OLD TIN ROOF OF THE
SHOTGUN HOUSE.
AND WE CRIED AND CRIED.
AND IN ONE CORNER OF THE OLD
HOUSE APPEARED TO BE LIFTING UP
AND MY AUNT WALKED OVER TO THAT
SIDE TO HOLD THE HOUSE DOWN WITH
HER BODY.
WHEN THE OTHER CORNER APPEARED
TO BE LIFTING SHE HAD US WALK TO
THAT CORNER, WE WERE CHILDREN
WALKING WITH THE WIND, BUT WE
NEVER, EVER LEFT THE HOUSE!
I SAY TO EACH OF YOU, EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US, THE WIND MAY
BLOW, THE THUNDER MAY ROLL, THE
LIGHTNING MAY FLASH AND THE RAIN
MAY BEAT DOWN ON AN OLD HOUSE,
CALL IT A HOUSE OF HARVARD, CALL
IT A HOUSE OF CAMBRIDGE, CALL IT
A HOUSE OF GLOUCESTER, CALL IT
THE HOUSE OF WASHINGTON, OR
ALABAMA OR GEORGIA, WE ALL LIVE
IN THE SAME HOUSE.
WE ALL MUST HOLD OUR LITTLE
HOUSE DOWN.
SO I SAY TO YOU: WALK WITH THE
WIND.
LET THE SPIRIT OF HISTORY BE
YOUR GUIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]